OKAY. WE ARE GOING TO. WE'RE
GOING TO START THE MEETING FOR
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. WE HAVE ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERE THAT WE
WILL GET TO MAKE THAT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE THAT WE'LL
GET STARTED WITH. WE'RE GOING TO
GO IN FILE ORDER. SO THIS IS
JUST A CALL OUT TO MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. IF THEY ARE
AVAILABLE TO COME ON DOWN,
THAT'D BE GREAT. AND TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE ITEMS IN FRONT
OF US TODAY, NOW WOULD BE THE
TIME TO MAKE YOUR WAY DOWN TO
ROOM 2103. ALMOST, ALMOST THERE
FOR A QUORUM? NOT QUITE. WE'LL
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
WHOLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HANEY,
ARE YOU READY TO GET STARTED?
YES. YOU ARE FIRST ON OUR FILE,
SIR. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. ALL
SET. SHOULD I START? YEAH. GO
RIGHT AHEAD. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AB 1775 IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF AB 374, WHICH
MANY OF YOU SUPPORTED LAST YEAR
AND WHICH RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AS IT WENT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THIS BILL WILL LEGALIZE CANNABIS
CAFES BY ALLOWING CANNABIS
RETAILERS TO SELL NON-CANNABIS
FOODS AND NONALCOHOLIC DRINKS,
AND WILL ALSO ALLOW RETAILERS TO
HOLD LIVE PERFORMANCES AT THEIR
VENUES. THIS BILL DOES NOT
LEGALIZE CONSUMPTION LOUNGES.
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES CURRENTLY
EXIST THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IF AUTHORIZED BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT, AND PEOPLE ARE
ACTIVELY CONSUMING CANNABIS AT
THESE LOUNGES. HOWEVER, WHAT IS
CURRENTLY NOT ALLOWED UNDER
EXISTING LAW COMPLETELY
PROHIBITED IS THE ABILITY FOR
CANNABIS RETAILERS TO DIVERSIFY
THEIR BUSINESSES BY SELLING
FOOD, DRINKS AND INEXPERIENCE.
IRONICALLY, WE REQUIRE UNDER
STATE LAW FOR CANNABIS RETAILERS
TO ONLY SELL CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS MERCHANDISE. WE BELIEVE
THAT IF WE WANT TO ALLOW FOR
PEOPLE TO MOVE AWAY FROM THAT
MODEL AND DIVERSIFY THEIR
BUSINESS AND CREATE AN
EXPERIENCE, THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO SO. WHY SHOULD WE ALLOW
IT? BECAUSE THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IS STRUGGLING. ISSUES
LIKE AN OVERSATURATION, HIGH
TAXES AND A STILL THRIVING BLACK
MARKET ARE HURTING CANNABIS
BUSINESSES WHO FOLLOW THE RULES
AND PAY TAXES BY AUTHORIZING
CANNABIS RETAILERS TO DIVERSIFY
THEIR BUSINESSES. WE ARE
BOOSTING REVENUE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESSES.
ADDITIONALLY, THESE VENUES ARE
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN DENSE
URBAN COMMUNITIES LIKE THOSE IN
MY DISTRICT AND DISTRICT. AND
THIS IS A WAY FOR US TO SUPPORT
OUR STATE'S RECOVERY. I WANT TO
LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT I
AMENDED THE BILL TO ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S CONCERNS ON WORKER
PROTECTIONS. RECENT AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT THE FOOD
PREPARATION AREA AND THE
CANNABIS CONSUMPTION AREA MUST
BE SEPARATED, AND THAT FOOD AND
CANNABIS CANNOT BE COMMINGLED.
WE ARE CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE TO TAKE
ON THE FLOOR TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS. AND HERE TO TESTIFY
WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS PAM LOPEZ
FROM CALIFORNIA NORML AND
KRISTIN HEIDELBACH FROM UFCW,
WHO REPRESENTS THE WORKERS. COME
ON, YOU CAN COME TO THE TABLE IF
YOU'D LIKE OR YOU CAN STAND
THERE, WHICHEVER IS EASIER.
WHATEVER. YOU WEREN'T SURE ABOUT
THIS? THAT'S ALL RIGHT. THE
FIRST ONE'S UP ARE ALWAYS THE
GUINEA PIGS. IT'S OKAY. SO,
MEMBER HANEY, YOU HAVE TWO
WITNESSES. THEY EACH GET TWO
MINUTES TO MAKE THEIR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU. PAM LOPEZ, ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA NORML, AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, HANEY STATED, CANNABIS
LOUNGES ARE ALREADY LEGAL AND
ALREADY EXIST IN CALIFORNIA,
ESPECIALLY IN URBAN COMMUNITIES
LIKE ASSEMBLYMEMBER HANEY'S
DISTRICT. AB 1775 SIMPLY
IMPROVES THE CONSUMER EXPERIENCE
BY ALLOWING CANNABIS CONSUMERS
TO BE SERVED NON ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES AND OR FOOD BEFORE
THEY LEAVE THE CANNABIS LOUNGE.
WE THINK THIS IS A SIMPLE
QUALITY OF LIFE IMPROVEMENT FOR
CANNABIS CONSUMERS, BUT ALSO A
GOOD SAFETY MEASURE FOR
COMMUNITIES. IT ALLOWS FOLKS TO
MAYBE HAVE A SANDWICH AND A CUP
OF COFFEE AND SOBER UP A LITTLE
BIT BEFORE THEY HEAD OUT OF THE
LOUNGE, CANNABIS LOUNGES ARE SO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IN URBAN
COMMUNITIES, NOT ONLY BECAUSE WE
WANT CONSUMERS TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSUME OUT OF
THEIR HOMES SO THAT PARENTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHO ARE CONSUMERS, WHO
ARE LIVING IN SMALL APARTMENTS,
MIGHT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
OUT OF THE HOME AND AWAY FROM
THEIR CHILDREN TO CONSUME. AND
SO THAT THOSE WHO ARE RENTING
AND ARE PROHIBITED FROM
CONSUMING IN THEIR HOMES HAVE A
SAFE PLACE TO GO THAT'S
APPROPRIATE, AS OPPOSED TO
STANDING ON A STREET CORNER OR
BEING IN A PARK WHERE THEY MIGHT
ENCOUNTER CHILDREN. BUT
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES ARE ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF CANNABIS CONSUMERS, OF WHICH
THERE ARE MILLIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE ADULT
LONELINESS IS AT ITS HIGHEST
LEVEL, AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
CONSUMERS TO HAVE A GOOD
EXPERIENCE WHERE THEY CAN GET
TOGETHER IN A SAFE PLACE,
CONSUME A LITTLE BIT OF
CANNABIS, BE WITH OTHER ADULTS,
HAVE A SANDWICH AND BUILD
COMMUNITY AND BE AROUND THEIR
FRIENDS. THANK YOU ALL FOR
CONSIDERING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. GOOD MORNING, KRISTIN
HEIDELBACH HERE ON BEHALF OF
UFCW WESTERN STATES COUNCIL AND
PROUD SUPPORT OF AB 1775, I WANT
TO START BY THANKING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY FOR AUTHORING THIS
BILL. UFCW REPRESENTS THOUSANDS
OF CANNABIS WORKERS IN THE
STATE. WE LOOK AT THIS AS A
POTENTIAL LIFELINE FOR
STRUGGLING BUSINESSES WHO NOW
HAVE A VERY LIMITED SCOPE THAT
THEY CAN OPERATE THEIR
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES. THIS ALLOWS
THEM TO RIGHT NOW, THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO HAVE PREPACKAGED
FOOD, BUT IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE A
COMMUNITY SETTING. A BAR WHERE
YOU WALK IN, SIT DOWN, ORDER
FOOD. THIS WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
PREPARE FRESH FOOD, ON SITE AND
CREATE MORE OF A BAR EXPERIENCE.
I APPRECIATE THIS BILL FROM
OBVIOUSLY THE WORKER
PERSPECTIVE, BUT ALSO FROM A
PARENT PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE IT
KEEPS PEOPLE OUT OF PARKS AND
OTHER PUBLIC SETTINGS WHERE THEY
MIGHT BE ENJOYING CANNABIS, THEY
CAN GO INTO A SPACE, EACH IT
SHOULD BE MENTIONED, OBVIOUSLY.
AND I THINK SOME OF THE
CONFUSION ON THIS BILL IS THAT
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES ALREADY
EXIST, SO THEY'RE ALREADY
ALLOWED. BUT THERE ARE ONLY A
NUMBER OF CITIES, A SMALL AMOUNT
OF CITIES THAT ARE ALLOWING
THEM, BUT EACH LOCAL WOULD BE
ABLE TO REALLY DRILL DOWN ON
THOSE REGULATIONS OR AN
ORDINANCE TO SEE WHAT WORKS BEST
FOR THEIR COMMUNITY. MAYBE THEY
HAVE A SMOKING BALCONY OUTSIDE.
MAYBE THEY HAVE AN ENCLOSED
SPACE, AND ALSO I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT NOT EVERYBODY
WANTS TO CONSUME CANNABIS BY
SMOKING. SOME FOLKS MAY WANT TO
ENJOY A BEVERAGE WHICH ARE
BECOMING MORE AND MORE POPULAR
OR EDIBLE. SO THERE IS WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS YOU
HAVE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE WORKERS PROTECTED. WE
BELIEVE THAT HAVING THAT
SEPARATION OF SPACE IS HELPFUL,
SO THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING
FOOD PREP, YOU KNOW, CAN IF THEY
WANT TO WORK IN A CONSUMPTION
AREA, THEY CAN DO SO WITHOUT
SMELLING, THE, THE HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THE FUMES FROM THE,
FROM THE CANNABIS, AND, AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR TO GET WHERE WE NEED
TO. SO WITH THAT, WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANKS FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD, I'M GOING TO WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM. SO I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THE ROLE. PLEASE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. ASHBY HERE. ASHBY HERE.
WHEN ALVARADO GIL. ALVARADO
HERE. ARCHULETA HERE. ARCHULETA.
HERE BECKER. BECKER. HERE. DODD.
EGGMAN. GLASER MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. HERE. NILO. NILO HERE.
ROTH. ROTH. HERE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK GREAT. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. SO WE CAN
PROCEED AS THE FULL COMMITTEE.
NOW, ARE THERE OTHER PEOPLE HERE
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT WITH ME TWO TESTIMONY.
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
AMELIA ZAMANI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION.
AN APOLOGIES. WE MISSED THE
LETTER DEADLINE, BUT WE'RE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. SARAH
NOCITO, ON BEHALF OF ORIGINS,
COUNSEL AND SUPPORT. RICH MILLER
ON BEHALF OF AMERICANS ALLIANCE
FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS AND
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? IF SO,
IF YOUR LEAD TESTIMONY, YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK, GO RIGHT
AHEAD. AND ACTUALLY, YOU CAN
COME UP TO THE TABLE AS WELL. IF
THERE ARE TWO OF YOU WHO ARE
PLANNING ON DOING LEAD
TESTIMONY, YOU CAN BOTH COME UP
TO THE TABLE. YOU'LL EACH GET
TWO MINUTES, JUST LIKE THE
PROPONENTS, AND THEN WE'LL DO ME
TWO TESTIMONY FOLLOWING. ALL
RIGHT, GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED.
TELL US YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION, AND THEN YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS KESHA BRUCE. I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY FOR THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION, THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY, CANCER
ACTION NETWORK, ACS CAN, THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION,
THÀNH, OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL
1775, WHICH WOULD CIRCUMVENT
CURRENT SMOKE FREE LAWS BY
BRINGING BACK THE SMOKE FILLED
RESTAURANT? IF APPROVED BY A
LOCAL JURISDICTION? SECONDHAND
SMOKE EXPOSURE IS TOXIC AND
DANGEROUS. IN 1995, CALIFORNIA
IMPLEMENTED A STATEWIDE SMOKE
FREE LAW IN RESTAURANTS, THEN
EXTENDED THOSE WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS TO WORKERS AND BARS.
IN 1998, AS A RESULT, ANYONE WHO
WORKS INDOORS CAN BE ASSURED
THAT THEY WILL NOT BE FORCED TO
WORK IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEIR HEALTH
DUE TO SMOKE. IN 2016,
CALIFORNIA PASSED PROPOSITION
64, LEGALIZING ADULT USE OF
CANNABIS AND THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AND SAFETY
GUIDELINES RELATED TO THE
SECONDHAND SMOKE RELATED TO
SECONDHAND SMOKE WERE INCLUDED.
BREATHING IN SECONDHAND SMOKE
CAUSES LUNG DISEASE. HEART
DISEASE, AND CANCER. ACCORDING
TO THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION, THERE IS
NO RISK FREE LEVEL OF SECONDHAND
SMOKE EXPOSURE. THE SCIENCE IS
CLEAR THERE IS NO VENTILATION OR
FILTRATION SYSTEM THAT CAN
CONTROL OR PREVENT EXPOSURE TO
SECONDHAND SMOKE. AB 1775 WILL
ERODE EXISTING SMOKE FREE INDOOR
AIR LAWS AND PUT A NEW CLASS OF
WORKERS AT RISK OF SECONDHAND
SMOKE EXPOSURE, ALLOWING THE
CANNABIS RETAIL INDUSTRY TO
EXPAND THEIR BUSINESS MODEL AT
THE EXPENSE OF STAFF AND
PERFORMERS. SAFETY IS DANGEROUS.
LAST YEAR, THE GOVERNOR CHOSE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF WORKERS BY
VETOING ASSEMBLY BILL 374. I ASK
YOU THAT YOU UPHOLD THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO BY MAINTAINING A
SAFE AND HEALTHY SMOKE FREE WORK
ENVIRONMENT AND ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT BRING BACK
THE TOXIC, SMOKE FILLED
RESTAURANT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL 1775.
THANK YOU. OKAY NEXT WITNESS.
HELLO. MY NAME. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. MY
NAME IS SUZANNE SCHICK AND I'M
AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, SAN FRANCISCO. FOR
THE PAST SEVEN YEARS, I HAVE
BEEN GOING OUT TO PUBLIC PLACES,
INCLUDING CANNABIS DISPENSARIES
AND MEASURING THE CONCENTRATIONS
OF VERY FINE PARTICLES IN THE
AIR. WE USE THE TERM PM 2.5 TO
REFER TO VERY FINE PARTICLES
THAT ARE SUSPENDED IN THE AIR,
THAT ARE SMALL ENOUGH TO GO ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO THE BOTTOM OF
YOUR LUNGS AND LEAD TO RAPID AND
BOTH RAPID AND LONG LASTING
CHANGES IN YOUR HEALTH, PRETTY
MUCH ANY PART OF YOUR BODY THAT
IS AFFECTED BY THE CIRCULATION
OF YOUR BLOOD HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO BE AFFECTED BY EXPOSURE TO
SECONDHAND SMOKE AND SMOKE IS
VERY CHEMICALLY SIMILAR. THE
ONLY SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SECONDHAND CANNABIS
SMOKE AND SECONDHAND TOBACCO
SMOKE IS THAT ONE CONTAINS THC
AND THE OTHER CONTAINS NICOTINE.
NOW, I'D LIKE EVERYBODY HERE TO
VISUALIZE AS AN AIR QUALITY
WILDFIRE OUTDOOR INDEX DAY WHERE
IT'S RED. THE AIR IS DESCRIBED
OFFICIALLY AS UNHEALTHY. YOU
MIGHT NOTICE SOME LOSS OF THE
ABILITY TO SEE IN THE DISTANCE
LAND MARKS START TO FADE OUT. IF
YOU LIVE IN LOS ANGELES, IT'S
THE DAY WHERE YOU CAN'T SEE THE
HILLS. YOU MIGHT AS IT GETS
HIGHER IN CONCENTRATIONS, START
NOTICING THAT THE QUALITY OF THE
AIR, THE COLORS SORT OF LIKE
GETTING ORANGEY BROWNISH. THIS
WHEN IT GETS. SO AT THAT POINT
YOU'RE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN, SAY,
150 AND 250 MICROGRAMS PER CUBIC
METER IN THE AIR, WHEN YOU GET
TO PURPLE, YOU'RE OVER 150, AND
SOMETIMES THE SUN STARTS TO LOOK
REDDISH, KIND OF LIKE A
MARASCHINO CHERRY. NOW I DID A
LOT TO WRAP UP SO LONG TERM
STUDY IN THE DISPENSARY IN
DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO OVER NINE
HOURS OF MEASUREMENTS ACROSS THE
WEEKS, ACROSS MONTHS, AVERAGE
CONCENTRATION WAS OVER 700.
THAT'S OFF THE AIR QUALITY INDEX
CHARTS IN THE UNITED STATES. NO,
PEOPLE DON'T CURL UP AND DIE THE
MOMENT THEY WALK IN, BUT THERE
IS VERY DEFINITELY AN INCREASED
RISK OF HEART ATTACKS AND HEALTH
RISKS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EXPERTISE AND FOR COMING
TODAY. THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
WITNESSES. ARE THERE FOLKS IN
THE ROOM WHO ARE ME TO
TESTIMONY, OPPOSITION? YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LEAVE. YOU CAN STAY
THERE TILL THE END OF THE
HEARING. YOU'RE FINE. GO AHEAD.
HELLO. GOOD MORNING, SYLVIA
SOLIS SHAW HERE. ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION,
JUST ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF
MISS BRUCE, HOW THIS WOULD UNDO
EXISTING SMOKE FREE PROTECTIONS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, ANYONE
ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE HEAR ME?
TWO TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY. WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS FOR QUESTIONS. SENATOR
ROTH, YOU KNOW, I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT, TOBACCO SMOKE.
I GO TO RESTAURANTS TO EAT. AND
SO I WAS VERY NOT SMOKE. AND SO
I WAS VERY PLEASED WHEN WE WHEN
THAT BAN WAS PUT IN PLACE AND I
NO LONGER HAD TO BREATHE SOMEONE
ELSE'S TOBACCO SMOKE AS I WAS
SITTING, TRYING TO ENJOY MY MEAL
. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WE
ULTIMATELY MAY FIND WITH RESPECT
TO THE SMOKE THAT COMES FROM
CANNABIS PRODUCTS, BUT I'M NOT
SURE THAT WE TOTALLY KNOW YET.
BUT THE MORE IMPORTANT THING, AS
I UNDERSTAND IT, IS THIS PROP
64. AUTHORIZED LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ESTABLISH
LOCATIONS DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE SMOKING AND OTHER
ACTIVITY ASSOCIATED WITH
CANNABIS, NOT RESTAURANTS FOR
EATING AND SO, YOU KNOW, IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT WHEN PEOPLE
CHOOSE TO GO TO THESE LOCATIONS,
THEY GO THERE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SMOKING. AND THOSE WHO DON'T
WANT TO PARTAKE OF CANNABIS BY
SMOKING OR EATING IT OR
WHATEVER, DON'T GO. AND SO WHY
WOULD YOU GO IF YOU'RE NOT
SMOKING CANNABIS? CGRTS WELL,
PROBABLY THEY PROBABLY. THAT'S
UP TO THE CHAIR. BUT THE POINT
IS, THAT'S HOW I SEE IT. MA'AM
DON'T GO IF YOU'RE NOT SMOKING
OR PARTICIPATING IN CANNABIS.
AND SO THE FACT THAT FOOD IS
PROVIDED AS AN INCIDENTAL AND BY
THE WAY, IT'S IN THE
PROPOSITION. SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THE VOTERS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
SPEAK IF WE WANT TO CHANGE THE
RULES OF THE ROAD AT THIS POINT.
SO I SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
THE IMPACTS, BOTH OF TOBACCO
SMOKE AND THE SMOKE OF CANNABIS.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
STUDIES BECAUSE AS THOSE STUDIES
COME OUT, IT MAY BE THAT EITHER
THE VOTERS OR THE LEGISLATURE
FIGURES OUT A WAY TO CHANGE THE
RULES OF THE ROAD. BUT UNTIL
THEN, I YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE
TODAY. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
OKAY. JUST TO BE CLEAR TO
EVERYONE IN THE ROOM, WE DON'T
SPEAK UNLESS A MEMBER ASKS YOU
DIRECTLY. AND THEN. AND THEN
WE'LL ALLOW FOR THE ANSWERS. GO
AHEAD. SENATOR ARCHULETA AND
THEN SENATOR NILO. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD, YOU HAD MENTIONED
THAT YOU HAD, I GUESS, CREATED
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE NOW
MADE IT MORE BUSINESS FRIENDLY.
I THINK, AND CERTAINLY TO
EVERYONE THAT'S CONCERNED, THERE
WAS SOME ISSUES THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAD, AND I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE NOW IN PLAY IS MUSIC.
AND SO NOW YOU HAVE A BAR
SETTING WHERE, YES, THERE'S FOOD
, THERE'S CONSUMPTION, AND IS IT
JUST THE DJ'S BANDS? IS IT
EXPANDING INTO A NIGHTCLUB
SITUATION? WHERE ARE WE WITH
THAT? SO, SO WE DIDN'T TAKE ANY
AMENDMENTS THAT CHANGED THE, THE
OPTION TO DO TICKETED EVENTS OR
SOME LIVE ENTERTAINMENT, THAT
WAS IN THE PREVIOUS VERSION OF
THE BILL. SO THAT'S THE SAME AS
IT WAS. AND, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
NOT ABOUT CREATING A NIGHTCLUB
OR ANYTHING. THESE CANNABIS
LOUNGES CAN HAVE MUSIC NOW, BUT
THIS MIGHT ALLOW THEM TO DO IS
HAVE, YOU KNOW, A JAZZ PERFORMER
OR A COMEDIAN OR SOME SOME SORT
OF EVENT TYPE THING. THIS IS ALL
ALSO TOTALLY AT THE DISCRETION
OF A OF A LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND
SO IF THEY WERE DOING ANYTHING
ELSE THAT REQUIRED APPROVAL,
THEY WOULD STILL NEED TO GO
THROUGH THEIR CITY. THEIR CITY
COULD STILL SAY, THEY CAN DO
THIS OR CAN'T DO THIS. AND, YOU
KNOW, ALL OF THAT REGULATION IS
STILL THERE. AND THEY'D HAVE TO
GO THROUGH ALL THOSE PROCESSES.
THIS WOULD AUTOMATICALLY ALLOW
THEM TO DO ANYTHING. IT WOULD
SIMPLY TAKE AWAY THE PROHIBITION
WHICH NOW CURRENTLY AT A
CANNABIS LOUNGE. YOU CAN'T MAKE
A SANDWICH AND SELL IT, AND YOU
ALSO CAN'T HAVE SOMEONE THERE
PLAYING A VIOLIN THAT YOU CHARGE
A TICKET FOR. SO CERTAINLY
THERE'S A LOT OF, I KNOW IN MY
CITY, A LOT OF STEPS YOU HAVE TO
TAKE. IF YOU WANTED TO DO
ANYTHING THAT WAS LOUD OR THAT
SORT OF THING. BUT BUT IT ALLOWS
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO. SO
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT POINT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND THEY STILL
HAVE JURISDICTION. THEY HAVE
SAY, AND I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE, THAT IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO BE THERE, DON'T GO.
YEAH. AND IF YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT OTHER THINGS, DON'T GO.
BUT I THINK THE PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
SPEAK. SO I'M GOING TO ALSO MOVE
FORWARD WITH IT AS WELL. AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS. SENATOR
NILO, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AS
I'VE SAID MANY TIMES, I AM TORN
ON THESE ISSUES BECAUSE I WAS
OPPOSED TO PROPOSITION 64 TO
BEGIN WITH, IT WAS A FLAWED,
TERRIBLY FLAWED PROPOSITION. AND
THAT'S WHY WE STRUGGLE WITH IT
SO MUCH. THE PROPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSITION WANTED IT TO PASS SO
BAD THAT THEY ALLOWED FOR THE
APPROVAL OF THE EXECUTION OF THE
ENABLEMENT OF PROPOSITION TO SO
MUCH SUCH A LARGE VARIANCE OF
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENTS THAT, IT'S
ITS EXECUTION HAS BEEN TERRIBLY
CONFUSED, NUMBER ONE. AND NUMBER
TWO, BECAUSE OF THAT WEAKNESS,
THE ILLEGAL MARKET CONTINUES TO
EXIST. THERE'S NOTHING DONE,
ABOUT THAT. WE DON'T HAVE THIS
PROPOSITION, DOESN'T PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES FOR THAT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I'M GOING TO ASK
A QUESTION OF THE OPPONENTS. AND
THIS IS NOT RHETORICAL. IT'S A
GENUINE QUESTION OF CURIOSITY,
BECAUSE I DON'T RECALL. DID YOU
FOLKS WORK AGAINST THE PROP, THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION 64? I
WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT PARTICULAR. SOMEBODY ELSE
HAS AN IDEA. I THINK, I CAN
SPEAK PERSONALLY. I WAS IN FAVOR
OF IT, MOSTLY BECAUSE OF THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS THAT, CANNABIS
OR THE POSITIVE EFFECTS ON
UNJUST INCARCERATION. THÀNH,
ALSO, WHEN IT PASSED, I WASN'T
IN THE BUSINESS OF STUDYING THE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF EXPOSURE TO
AIR POLLUTION. THAT WAS A WAYS
BACK. THAT'S I THINK, WHEN Kò IS
STRUGGLING IS THAT WAS A LONG
TIME AGO. AND WE DON'T HAVE YOUR
YOU KNOW, ADVANTAGES OF HAVING
BEEN IN THE GAME THAT LONG. THE
MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS THAT THE
OPPONENTS TO THIS, BILL WERE
LARGELY NOT INVOLVED IN THE
CAMPAIGN ON THAT PROPOSITION,
WHICH DISAPPOINTED ME, THIS
ISSUE OF SECONDHAND SMOKE HAS
REALLY NOT RISEN TO THE
FOREFRONT WITH CANNABIS LIKE IT
IS WITH TOBACCO. WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF ANALYSIS,
I'LL SAY, WITHOUT PREJUDICING MY
COMMENT, OF TOBACCO SMOKING
VERSUS CANNABIS SMOKING MARKEDLY
DIFFERENT, CANNABIS SMOKING.
OKAY. TOBACCO SMOKING NOT OKAY.
THAT ALWAYS FRUSTRATES ME. NOW,
HAVING SAID THAT, PROPOSITION 64
WAS PASSED, WE HAVE A STRUGGLING
LEGAL MARKET AND A THRIVING
ILLEGAL MARKET, AND I JUST HAVE
TO ASK MYSELF, OKAY, I'M OPPOSED
TO IT, BUT WHICH ONE WOULD I
RATHER SEE ENABLED? AND I WOULD
RATHER SEE THE LEGAL MARKET
ENABLED. IT'S IT IT PAINS ME TO
SAY THAT, BUT I VOTED IN FAVOR
OF THESE ENABLEMENTS FOR THE
LEGAL MARKET ALL ALONG, EVEN
THOUGH I DO IT WITH A BIT OF A
TROUBLED, NOTION BECAUSE.
BECAUSE THE ILLEGAL MARKET IS
WINNING THE GAME, THE GAME AND
THE LEGAL MARKET IS AT LEAST A
BETTER ALTERNATIVE OF SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS HARMFUL, NOT
JUST BECAUSE OF SECONDHAND
SMOKE, BUT, BECAUSE OF THE
EFFECTS OF MARIJUANA, I WON'T GO
ALL INTO THAT ARGUMENT, BUT I
PERSONALLY HAVE THOSE CONCERNS,
AND IT IS AT LEAST PARTIALLY BY
PERSONAL OBSERVATION. SO LET YOU
WERE, CLAMORING TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION OF CHOOSE TO GO. SO I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU DIRECTLY IF YOU
WOULD ADDRESS THAT. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY, MY RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT YOUR BODY'S RESPONSE
TO BREATHING SECONDHAND SMOKE,
ESPECIALLY ITS RISKS FOR YOUR
HEART, FOR HEART ATTACKS AND
STROKES, HAPPENS INSTANTANEOUSLY
WITHIN A MINUTE OR TWO, EASILY
VISIBLE WITHIN 30 MINUTES. I
SPEND TIME IN DISPENSARIES.
PLENTY OF PEOPLE COME IN WITH
THEIR FRIENDS. OFTENTIMES A
WOMAN WITH HER HUSBAND OR HER
BOYFRIEND. THEY'RE NOT
CONSUMING, BUT THEY'RE KEEPING
THEM COMPANY. THERE'S ALSO
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T THERE FOR THE
CANNABIS AT ALL WHO ARE JUST
WORKING PEOPLE. THEY'RE
DELIVERING PARCELS. PEOPLE ARE
REPAIRING THE HVAC. PEOPLE ARE
DOING WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN
BUSINESSES. THEY AREN'T THERE BY
CHOICE AND THEY AREN'T THERE FOR
LONG, BUT THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
A TRANSITORY, SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE BY ANYWHERE. BETWEEN 5
AND 30% IN THEIR RISK OF A HEART
ATTACK. IN THE MOMENT, IF YOU
WOULD VISUALIZE SOMEONE WHO'S
NEAR RETIREMENT AGE WORKING ON
THE VENTILATION SYSTEM, I GET, I
GET ALL OF THE REASONS ABOUT THE
SECONDHAND SMOKE. I WAS JUST
ASKING, YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
COMMENT, IF PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
GO, THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO. YOU
DID ADDRESS THAT A LITTLE BIT,
BUT IT WAS MOSTLY ABOUT
SECONDHAND. THE EFFECT OF
SECONDHAND SMOKE, I GET THAT.
SO, CAN YOU REFINE? CAN YOU WHAT
ARE YOU REALLY. WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO MOVE ON. FROM THAT
POINT, SENATOR NILO. SO, ONE
OTHER QUESTION. THERE IS A LONG
HISTORY OF PEOPLE USING
MARIJUANA. WHAT MEDICAL EVIDENCE
DO WE HAVE OF THOSE PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM THE EFFECTS OF
THE SMOKE? QUALITY OF EVIDENCE
HISTORICALLY IS VERY LOW BECAUSE
A LOT OF PEOPLE, WHEN IT'S
ILLEGAL, DON'T WANT TO ADMIT TO
DOING IT. AND THE WAY PEOPLE
HAVE ASKED RESEARCHERS HAVE
ASKED QUESTIONS WAS LIKE, HAVE
YOU EVER USED IT? RATHER THAN DO
YOU USE IT REGULARLY? BUT
BETTER, MORE RECENT DATA ON
CURRENT REGULAR USERS SHOWS
INCREASED RISKS OF HEART
DISEASE, I APOLOGIZE FOR, THE
LENGTH OF MY QUESTIONING AND
COMMENTS, BUT, I FELT COMPELLED
TO EXPRESS MY TERRIBLE
FRUSTRATION WITH THIS. AND WHILE
NOT WHOLLY HAPPY WITH IT, I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL. OKAY, I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER COMMENTS. I DO
HAVE A COMMENT ON THIS ITEM. YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES CHAIRS OF
COMMITTEES WILL ISSUE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE BODY. AND
THIS ONE I DID NOT. I DID A NON
RECO, WHICH MEANS EVERYBODY GETS
TO MAKE UP THEIR OWN MIND
WITHOUT INTERFERENCE FROM ME.
HOWEVER, I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAYNIE KNOWS THIS. I AM DEEPLY
TROUBLED BY THIS BILL, SO I
PERSONALLY WILL BE VOTING NO,
BUT HAVE LEFT THE COMMITTEE OPEN
TO DO AS THEY PLEASE. THAT BEING
SAID, I WOULD NEED A MOTION. SO
MOVE, MOVE BY SENATOR RATH. WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
HANEY, WOULD YOU LIKE I MEAN,
I'M SORRY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY
. I PROMOTED YOU ALREADY. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I APPRECIATE
THAT, AND I APPRECIATE ALL ALL
OF THE COMMENTS, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S EXISTING CANNABIS
LOUNGES THAT WAS PUT INTO LAW BY
THE VOTERS. WE'RE MAKING IT VERY
HARD FOR THOSE BUSINESSES TO
SURVIVE, TO THRIVE. THEY'RE
LOSING TO THE ILLEGAL MARKET.
THIS IS ABOUT GIVING LOCAL
CONTROL AND SUPPORTING OUR LEGAL
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THEIR
ABILITY TO ADAPT AND BE FLEXIBLE
WITH THEIR BUSINESSES AND
PROVIDE FOR AN EXPERIENCE AND A
PRODUCT THAT PEOPLE WANT. IT
WILL CREATE JOBS AND REVENUE.
AND I HOPE THAT HOWEVER YOU FEEL
ABOUT CANNABIS, THAT WE CAN GET
BEHIND SUPPORTING THESE
BUSINESSES AND THEIR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY SURVIVE. WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALL
RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR. ASHBY. NO.
ASHBY. NO WHEN. NO. WHEN. NO.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. A
ARCHULETA. I BECKER. BECKER. I
DODD. I DODD I EGGMAN. GLAZER.
MENGIBAR NILO. NILO I ROTH I
ROTH I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK.
ALL RIGHT, THAT'S FIVE YESES,
TWO NO'S. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. GOT A LOT MORE MEMBERS TO
COME DOWN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES FOR
YOUR EXPERT TESTIMONY. WE
APPRECIATE YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM. WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
HERE. MR. PATTERSON, YOU READY
TO COME FORWARD AND YOU CAN HAVE
YOUR WITNESSES TAKE THE TABLE
TOO. IF YOU HAVE THEM WITH YOU
ALREADY. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY OF
PRESENTING AB 2471, LET ME FIRST
JUST NOTE THAT THE BILL HAS SOME
SIGNIFICANT, ORGANIZATIONAL AND
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT. THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING SUPPORTS
THE BILL, THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT AS WELL. AND
WHAT THE BILL ATTEMPTS TO DO, IS
. IN SOME WAY, APPROACH THE NEED
TO LOWER SOME BARRIERS FOR
RETIRED NURSING NURSES TO COME
BACK IN TO NURSING, AND LET ME
GO INTO THE DETAILS. PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES PLAY A CRUCIAL
ROLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THEY
PROMOTE BETTER HEALTH, ENSURING
THAT MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. THE IMPORTANT THING
HERE IS, THOUGH, THAT THEIR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE DOES NOT
EXTEND BEYOND THAT OF REGISTERED
NURSE, AND THAT IS ONE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES HERE.
WHY WE ARE DOING WHAT WE ARE
DOING CURRENTLY, REGISTERED
NURSES ARE REQUIRED TO PAY A
NONREFUNDABLE FEE FOR THE
EVALUATION OF THEIR
QUALIFICATIONS TO USE THE TITLE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE. THIS IS
IN ADDITION TO THEIR REGULAR RN
LICENSE RENEWAL THAT THEY ARE
ALREADY THEY COMPLETE EVERY TWO
YEARS. HERE'S WHAT THE BILL DOES
AND I WANT TO SAY WHY AB 2471
WOULD SIMPLIFY THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS, AND IT WOULD ELIMINATE
THE UNNECESSARY EXTRA RENEWAL
FEE AND PROCESS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN PAYING AND COMPLETING EVERY
TWO YEARS SINCE. THEY DO NOT
HAVE AN EXPANDED SCOPE OF
PRACTICE BEYOND THAT OF RN, THEY
DO NOT HAVE THE NEED FOR THE
RENEWAL FEE. WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS TO IS, I THINK,
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO TRY TO
PUT SOME BARRIERS DOWN SO THAT
WE GET MORE NURSES INTO THE INTO
THE, INTO THE FIELD, AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE RETIRED
NURSES WHO'VE DONE IT FOR A GOOD
LONG TIME. THEY'RE GOOD AT IT,
AND BY BY SUPPORTING THE BILL,
WHAT WE DO HERE IS WE REMOVE
THAT ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT,
ASSOCIATE AND THE ASSOCIATED FEE
THAT HELPS TO REDUCE THE OVERALL
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF THESE
NURSES, THAT HELPS THE COMMUNITY
TO RECRUIT, BUT IT ALSO REDUCES
IMPEDIMENTS FOR RETIRED NURSES
WHO WANT TO RETURN TO THE
WORKFORCE. AND HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2471 IS MARISSA
CLARK WITH THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR, VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MARISSA CLARK WITH THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2471. AS THE
MEMBER SAID, CURRENTLY, A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE MUST APPLY AND PAY
A FEE TO RENEW THEIR R.N.
LICENSE AS WELL AS APPLY AND PAY
A FEE TO RENEW THEIR PUBLIC
HEALTH CERTIFICATE EVERY TWO
YEARS. THIS PROCESS DOES MIRROR
THE PROCESS FOR ADVANCED
PRACTICE REGISTERED NURSES. THE
MAIN DIFFERENCE, HOWEVER, IS
THAT ADVANCED PRACTICE
REGISTERED NURSES DO HAVE AN
EXPANDED SCOPE OF PRACTICE, AND
THAT EXPANDED SCOPE OF PRACTICE
CAN INCUR ADDITIONAL
INVESTIGATION AND ENFORCEMENT
COSTS. THE BOARD IS ABLE TO
RECOUP THOSE COSTS THROUGH THAT
BIENNIAL RENEWAL CERTIFICATE
FEE. SO WHILE PUBLIC HEALTH
EXCUSE ME PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
COMPLETES SPECIALIZED COURSEWORK
AND CLINICAL EXPERIENCE TO
OBTAIN THEIR CERTIFICATE, THEY
DO NOT HAVE THAT EXPANDED SCOPE
OF PRACTICE BEYOND THAT OF AN
RN, WHICH MEANS THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE SAME NEED FOR A BIENNIAL
CERTIFICATE RENEWAL FEE. SINCE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES WOULD STILL
BE REQUIRED TO RENEW THEIR RN
LICENSE EVERY TWO YEARS. WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT REMOVING THE
CERTIFICATE RENEWAL WOULD BE AN
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SAFETY RISK.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT AS THE BILL
WOULD HELP TO EASE THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN OF MAINTAINING A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE CERTIFICATE AND
ASSIST IN CRITICAL COMMUNITY
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHERS HERE
IN SUPPORT WHO WOULD LIKE TO
COME FORWARD WITH THEIR ME TO
TESTIMONY, YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL? THANK YOU. DYLAN
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF HUMBOLDT AND LARRY,
BOTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. JOE SIGNS
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION,
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT. GREAT.
ALL RIGHT. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION OF AB
2471? SEEING NO ONE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES MOVED
BY SENATOR ROTH, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YEAH.
I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AS
LISTED. BEFORE YOU, AND ALSO
JUST A REITERATION THAT THIS
DOES REMOVE AN UNNECESSARY
BARRIER. AND BY REMOVING IT, IT
IS AN ENCOURAGEMENT,
PARTICULARLY FOR RETIRED NURSES
TO THINK ABOUT COMING BACK INTO
THE FIELD. AND WE NEED THEM,
PARTICULARLY IN ONE OF THE
REASONS I AUTHORED IT. AND HOPE
YOU WILL PASS IT, IS THAT
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA REALLY DOES
HAVE A NURSE SHORTAGE ISSUES,
AND WE THINK THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE AN INCENTIVE AND AN
ENCOURAGEMENT FOR NURSES TO COME
BACK OUT OF RETIREMENT, BRING
THEIR SKILLS TO THE THOSE THAT
NEED IT. AND I THINK BETTER
HEALTH WILL BE A RESULT. SO ON
BEHALF OF THOSE, WHO SUPPORT WHO
ARE HERE AND ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
AS THE AUTHOR, I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR ROTH. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE ROLE. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
HI. ASHBY I WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO. GIL I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I BECKER I
BECKER I DODD DODD I EGGMAN.
GLASER MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NILO
NILO I ROTH ROTH I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK. ALL RIGHT, THAT'S
NINE YESES, BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN TO. AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANKS FOR YOUR EXPERT.
THANK YOU. TESTIMONY. WE ARE
GOING MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT. AND THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR. YOU BET. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO HANG OUT FOR A SECOND
AND WAIT FOR AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO.
OKAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GARCIA,
ARE YOU READY TO GET STARTED
HERE? IF SO, WE'LL HAVE YOU COME
TO THE PODIUM. AND ANY LEAD
WITNESS YOU HAVE CAN COME TO THE
TABLE. ALL RIGHT. ANY PREFERENCE
OR WHICH ONE GOES FIRST? WE WILL
START WITH A B. 2860. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR, 2860
REMOVES THE PILOT STATUS OF THIS
PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM IS THE
DOCTORS AND DENTISTS FROM MEXICO
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
ABOUT 20 YEARS AGO TO REALLY
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF DOCTORS,
PHYSICIANS IN MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AS A MEMBER OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS, WHO'S NO
LONGER WITH US, MARCO ANTONIO
FIREBAUGH 20 YEARS AGO HAD THE
VISION TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA,
COULD DEVELOP A PROGRAM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR MEDICAL
PROGRAMS, UNIVERSITIES IN MEXICO
TO BE ABLE TO FILL IN THESE GAPS
. AND TODAY, MORE THAN EVER, WE
SEE THE NEED, UP AND DOWN RURAL
AND URBAN PARTS OF THE STATE FOR
MORE DOCTORS, MORE DENTISTS, TO
SERVE A POPULATION THAT REQUIRES
DOCTORS THAT ARE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT, THAT SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE, AND THAT CAN HELP
ADDRESS THIS MAJOR SHORTAGE, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. OUR WITNESSES HAVE BEEN
TOLD TO KEEP IT SHORT AND SWEET
TO THE POINT, AND SO WE'LL DEFER
NOW TO THEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE TWO MINUTES FOR
EACH OF YOU. GO AHEAD AND MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU. YES.
MY NAME IS, ARNOLDO TORRES, ONE
OF THE CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL,
AN ARTICLE THAT CAME OUT LAST
WEEK, FOREIGN PHYSICIANS CAN
HELP SOLVE AMERICA'S DOCTOR
SHORTAGE IN THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL, THESE ARTICLES ARE
QUITE COMMON NOWADAYS IN THE
UNITED STATES. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PANEL UNDERSTANDS
THAT WE'RE NOT DOING THIS
BECAUSE WE'RE ON THIS,
INCLUSIVE, DIVERSITY AGENDA.
THIS IS SIMPLY THE PRACTICAL
REALITY OF ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
DOCTORS. THERE ARE MORE HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREAS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ACTUALLY BEAT TEXAS, WHICH IS AN
ABSOLUTE SHOCK TO SOME OF US WHO
STUDY THIS STUFF ALL THE TIME.
BY OVER 250 MORE HIPS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ON THIS
PANEL, EIGHT OF YOU WILL HAVE
DOCTORS UNDER THIS PROGRAM,
UNDER THE EXPANSION THAT, MR.
GARCIA IS CARRYING FOR US, THE
PILOT PROGRAM HAS PROVEN TO BE
VERY EFFECTIVE, WE'RE VERY HAPPY
TO HAVE WORKED WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF IN STRENGTHENING
THE BILL AND WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD, WE FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE
THAT THE EXPANSION OF THIS
PROGRAM WILL CREATE PHENOMENAL
ACCESS TO A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION. WHO
DOES NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT DOCTORS. AND THAT'S
THE REALITY. CALIFORNIA CANNOT
PRODUCE THEM ANYWHERE CLOSE TO
IN TIME TO PROVIDE THAT ACCESS.
AND WE HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WILL RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE, PREVENTIVE
PRIMARY CARE TO ALL CALIFORNIA
WHO LIVE AND WORK IN THIS STATE
WITH ME IS, DENNIS, ROMERO
CUEVAS ROMERO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION, CO-SPONSOR OF THE
BILL. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS DENNIS ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION ADVOCATES AND
CO-SPONSOR THE BILL, REALLY
PROUD TO BE CO-SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL, THERE WILL BE AT LEAST OR
NEARLY 15 ADDITIONAL HEALTH
CENTERS UP AND DOWN THE STATE,
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
EXPANSION FOR HEALTH CENTERS.
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT CARE,
LAST THING I'LL MENTION FOR
HEALTH CENTERS, WHEN THEY LOSE A
PHYSICIAN, IT TAKES AT LEAST 28
WEEKS TO TRY TO GET A
REPLACEMENT PHYSICIAN IN THEIR
CLINIC. SO PROGRAMS LIKE THESE
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. SO ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WITH ME TO TESTIMONY,
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. GOOD MORNING.
REBECCA ALCANTARA, ON BEHALF OF
ALTAMED HEALTH SERVICES AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MEMBERS, AARON BOWEN
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE SUPPORT IF
AMENDED, BUT WORKING VERY
PRODUCTIVELY WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR ON THE REMAINING ISSUES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL? I SEE NO LEAD
WITNESSES. ANYBODY WHO JUST
WANTS TO ME TO OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT, THEN WE'RE
GOING TO COME BACK TO THE DAIS
FOR QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES.
Tð AT THE END DOWN THERE,
SENATOR MARIA ALVARADO GIL AND
THEN MENGIBAR SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MEMBER
GARCIA, I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR INTENT IN
THIS BILL TO HELP SERVE THE NEED
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES AND TO
BRING, SPANISH AS A PRIMARY
LANGUAGE INTO CALIFORNIA, WHICH
IS SO MUCH IN NEED IN THE HEALTH
CARE AREA AND PUBLIC HEALTH. SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND I ALSO
WANT TO CONFIRM MY REQUEST TO
COAUTHOR THIS BILL AS WELL. SO
THANK YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME.
GREAT. SENATOR MENGIBAR AND THEN
SENATOR ROTH, I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, YOU'RE GOING TO GET SOME
PRAISES OVER HERE, I WANT TO
ECHO MY COLLEAGUE AS WELL. THIS
IS A REALLY EXCITING BILL FOR
ME. YOU AND I AND THE SPONSORS
HAVE HAD, HAVE HAD CONVERSATION
ON ENSURING AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THAT WE ADD OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
WE CAN FURTHER EXPAND TO MEET
THE NEED HERE IN CALIFORNIA. GO
AHEAD. SENATOR ROTH, JUST A
COMMENT, THIS IS A CRITICAL
BILL. IT'S A SHAME IT TOOK SO
LONG TO GET THE PROGRAM UP AND
RUNNING. I'M GLAD IT'S UP AND
RUNNING. IT DOES NEED TO BE
EXPANDED. I'M GLAD THAT IT'S
GOING TO HAVE A LIFE THAT
CONTINUES, IT IS, UNFORTUNATE
THAT THE DENTAL PROGRAM HASN'T,
AS MY UNDERSTANDING, HASN'T
MOVED FORWARD. AS WELL. BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
TAKES OFF BECAUSE THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF DENTISTS IN THESE
UNDERSERVED AREAS AS WELL. AND
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN TO, MAYBE EVEN FIND SOME
FUNDING TO GET THAT OFF THE
GROUND AND GET THAT IN PLACE AS
WELL. BUT I AM DELIGHTED TO SEE
THIS EFFORT, AND I WILL MOVE THE
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE POINT IN
TIME. GREAT. THANK YOU. SENATORS
ARCHULETA. AND THEN NILO. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. I'VE HAD THE
OCCASION TO MEET WITH ALTAMED
AND GIVE A SPEECH THERE AT THEIR
CLINICS. WE HAVE SEVERAL IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN SPEAKING WITH
THE PATIENTS, THIS WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME. SPEAKING WITH
THE PATIENTS, THEY WERE SO HAPPY
TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THEIR DOCTOR, TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM IN SUCH A WAY THAT
THEY DIDN'T FEEL THAT THEY
NEEDED AN INTERPRETER. THEY WERE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY TALK TO THE
DOCTOR AND, AND, AND, AND FROM
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT I
TALKED TO, EVEN THE DOCTORS
THEMSELVES THAT WERE SO GLAD
THAT NOT JUST ULTIMATE, BUT
OTHER CLINICS IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT I SERVE IN, SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES SERVE SAME THING.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE MORE DOCTORS,
THERE'S NO DOUBT. AND AND, AND I
HOPE THIS IS A WAKE UP CALL TO
OUR MEDICAL SCHOOLS THAT WE'VE
GOT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
RECRUIT ROOT, YOU KNOW, OUR, OUR
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE IN
COLLEGES AND HIGH SCHOOLS THAT
THEY'RE NEEDED AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT ARE BILINGUAL. SO I'M
HOPE TO BE A COAUTHOR AS WELL.
SO PUT ME DOWN FOR THAT. AND I
WISH YOU MUCH SUCCESS WITH YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MADAM CHAIR. GREAT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NILO. SENATOR
ARCHULETA JUST PROMOTED YOU. YES
MADAM CHAIR. YEAH I HAVE A
QUESTION THAT, RELATES TO WHAT
SENATOR ARCHULETA JUST SAID.
THIS PROGRAM IS NEEDED, AND IT
OBVIOUSLY IS FOR CULTURAL AND
COMMUNICATION PURPOSES, BUT ALSO
BECAUSE WE HAVE A GENERAL
SHORTAGE OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IN THIS STATE. AND
THE FACT THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
SUCCESSFUL AS IT IS, DOCTORS
COMING FROM MEXICO, THAT MIGHT
IMPLY, BY IMPLICATION, THAT
MEXICO DOES NOT HAVE A SHORTAGE
OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS OR
DOCTORS SPECIFICALLY. AND IF
THAT'S THE CASE, WHY NOT THERE?
AND WHY HERE? WELL, EXCELLENT
QUESTION. AND I WILL ASK OUR
WITNESS TO ALSO CHIME IN. BUT
THE FACT IS, IS THAT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO STATE THIS ISN'T
THE SOLUTION TO OUR DOCTOR
SHORTAGES. AND I WANT TO I JUST
NO, I JUST WANT TO PREFACE MY
RESPONSE WITH THAT FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES MEDICAL SCHOOLS
THAT ARE WATCHING, THAT ARE
LISTENING, THIS IS NOT THE END
ALL, BE ALL SOLUTION TO OUR
PROBLEM, SENATOR ARCHULETA HIT
THE NAIL ON THE HEAD. WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. AT OUR
MEDICAL SCHOOLS TO ACCELERATE
AND TO BUILD MEDICAL PROGRAMS
THAT ARE TAILORED AROUND THE
POPULATIONS OF CALIFORNIA AND
ITS NEEDS. AND WE HAVE NOT DONE
SO, TO THE POINT THAT WE'RE
BRINGING THAT WE'RE BORROWING
DOCTORS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES. A
CASE IN POINT FROM MEXICO.
MEXICO DOES NOT WANT THESE
DOCTORS TO STAY HERE AND
PRACTICE FOREVER. THEY ARE
EDUCATING THEM. THEY ARE PAYING
FOR THEM TO BE EDUCATED, TO
SERVE MEXICANOS IN MEXICO, BUT
BUT THEY BELIEVE THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT, GIVEN THE
RELATIONSHIP TO CALIFORNIA, NOT
JUST THE ECONOMIC RELATIONSHIP.
WE ARE THE LARGEST TRADE
PARTNER, TO MEXICO, CALIFORNIA,
BEING THAT PARTNER AND ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF, MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS HAPPEN TO BE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THERE IS A VESTED
INTEREST, THAT PEOPLE OF MEXICAN
DESCENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
HEALTHY AND ARE ALSO, INVOLVED
IN THE ECONOMIC ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE IN MEXICO, THE LARGEST
ECONOMIC FUNDING SOURCE IS,
COMING BACK. I'M GETTING TO YOUR
QUESTION, SENATOR. THE PROBLEM
IS HERE IN CALIFORNIA, IN OUR
MEDICAL SCHOOLS. AND IF WE WANT
TO SEE MORE DOCTORS, COMING FROM
OUR COMMUNITIES, THEN WE NEED TO
EVALUATE THE MEDICAL SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND HOW THEY ARE
FUNCTIONING TO BE ABLE TO
PREPARE STUDENTS AS, POPULATIONS
THAT LOOK LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
POPULATION, IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THESE
SHORTAGES, NOT JUST IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA, BUT IN URBAN
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M GOING TO ASK
ONE OF THE WITNESSES WHO MIGHT
BE ABLE TO GET FURTHER IN THE
WEEDS, GET INTO THAT. BEFORE WE
DO THAT, LET'S JUST. SENATOR, DO
YOU HAVE THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION OR DO YOU WANT TO
REFINE IT? NO, NO, I DON'T. I
GET THE CULTURAL ISSUE AND THE
DIVERSITY OF DOCTORS THAT ARE
EITHER GRADUATED OR NOT
GRADUATED, BUT WE CLEARLY HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF DOCTORS IN
CALIFORNIA, NOT JUST THOSE TO
SERVE A DISADVANTAGED AREAS, TO
SERVE THE LATINO POPULATION, TO
SERVE OTHER IMMIGRATION
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS THAT HAVE
MOVED HERE RECENTLY, LIKE FROM
UKRAINE AND OTHERWISE. BUT WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE OF DOCTORS AND
EVIDENTLY MEXICO DOES NOT. SO
WHAT ARE THEY DOING DIFFERENTLY
IN MEXICO THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
HERE, UNDER THIS, UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION IN
MEXICO, HE CLAIMED THAT THERE
WAS A SHORTAGE AND THERE IS NO
SHORTAGE. HE WENT TO CUBA AND
BROUGHT DOCTORS IN AND OFFENDED,
A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF DOCTORS
IN MEXICO. MEXICO DOES THE
FOLLOWING. MEXICO ASSESSES WHAT
ITS POPULATION NEEDS, HOW MANY
DOCTORS IT ACTUALLY NEEDS TO
HAVE IN MEDICAL SCHOOL TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE THE POPULATION
THAT IS IN THE COUNTRY OF
MEXICO, AND THAT'S HOW THEY DO
IT. WE DON'T DO IT THAT WAY IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
MEXICO'S EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IS
BUILT. ITS, MEDICAL SCHOOLS ARE
BUILT AROUND THAT. THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT THE, LEVEL OF
EXCELLENCE WITHIN THE MEDICAL
SCHOOLS IN MEXICO DOES VARY
SIGNIFICANTLY, WE'RE VERY
CAREFUL TO SELECT THOSE THAT ARE
GOING TO MEET THE STANDARDS THAT
WE HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
MEXICO, AGAIN, FUNDAMENTALLY,
ASSESSES WHAT ITS POPULATION
REQUIRES, IT LIVES BY THE ALMOST
THE US STANDARDS. ONE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN FOR EVERY 3000 IN
AN URBAN CENTER, OR IN AN URBAN
CENTER IS 3500 PER PRIMARY CARE
IN A RURAL AREA. IT'S ONE FOR
3000. SO THEY RECRUIT THAT,
ADMIT, ENOUGH STUDENTS TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO MEET WHATEVER THOSE
NEEDS ARE. WE DON'T DO IT THAT
WAY. AND WE'VE NEVER DONE IT
THAT WAY, WHICH IS WHY WE'RE SO
FAR BEHIND, AND UNTIL WE DO IT
THAT WAY, WHICH WILL TAKE AT
LEAST 30 TO 40 TO 50 YEARS, WE
HAVE TO DEPEND, IN ESSENCE, FOR
OUR POPULATION ON MEXICO, THESE
DOCTORS COME HERE FOR ONLY THREE
YEARS, AND THEN THEY RETURN.
OKAY. SENATOR NILO, SENATOR ROTH
WOULD LIKE TO CONTRIBUTE TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION IF THAT
WOULD BE OKAY. YES. AND I'M
SORRY FOR, AGAIN, BELABORING THE
DISCUSSION BEYOND WHAT MAYBE IT
SHOULD BE. BUT THE LAST POINT
I'D MAKE IS THAT IS AN
INTERESTING CONCEPT, THAT THAT
IS THAT OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT EDUCATORS ARE
ACTUALLY LOOKING TO THE NEEDS OF
THE ECONOMY IN ORDER TO PROVIDE,
THE APPROPRIATE STUDY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS AND
TRYING TO GUIDE THEM IN THAT
DIRECTION SO THAT OUR COLLEGE
GRADUATES ACTUALLY MEET THE
REQUIREMENT OF THE JOBS
AVAILABLE. AND YOU'RE RIGHT, WE
DO NOT DO THAT, NOT JUST IN
HEALTH, BUT OTHER AREAS. ALSO,
SENATOR ROTH, JUST TO RESPOND TO
SENATOR NEAL'S QUESTION, ONE OF
THE OBVIOUSLY MEDICAL SCHOOLS
ARE EXPENSIVE AND IT'S DIFFICULT
TO START THEM AND MAINTAIN THEM.
BUT ONE OF THE LARGER ISSUES
HERE I DON'T KNOW ABOUT MEXICO
IS THAT THAT IN CALIFORNIA, IN
THE UNITED STATES, AS A GRADUATE
M.D, YOU CANNOT PRACTICE UNLESS
YOU COMPLETE A RESIDENCY PROGRAM
. YOU CANNOT GET A CONTRACT TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE SERVICES
WITH A PROVIDER WITH A HEALTH
PLAN, UNLESS YOU COMPLETE A
RESIDENCY PROGRAM OF VARYING
LENGTHS FROM USUALLY THREE YEARS
TO FOUR TO 5 TO 6, DEPENDING ON
WHAT FIELD YOU'RE IN. AND
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS ARE EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE THEY ENTAIL PAYING FOR
THE SALARY OF THE RESIDENT AND
THE BENEFITS OF THE RESIDENT,
AND ALSO FINDING CLINICAL
FACILITIES THAT HAVE SLOTS TO
PLACE THEM. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, LARGELY, PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND
THEY DO IT THROUGH THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM AND PRIMARILY AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS NOT
INCREASED RESIDENCY SLOTS, WITH
SOME EXCEPTIONS, IN THE UNITED
STATES SINCE THE 1990S. THE
STATE ATTEMPTS TO PROVIDE SOME
FUNDING THROUGH SONG, BROWN AND
OTHER PROGRAMS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT OF COURSE, OUR
ABILITY TO DO SO IS LIMITED TO
OUR GENERAL FUND. AS WE'VE SEEN
IN THIS BUDGET WHERE THERE WERE
CUTS AND THAT'S REALLY THE
LIMITING FACTOR BEYOND SIMPLY
MEDICAL SCHOOL, MEDICAL SCHOOL
ABILITY AND CAPACITY. IT'S THE
IT'S THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM SLOTS
AND THE AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL
TRAINING, WHICH OF COURSE IS
TRUE FOR A LOT OF OTHER HEALTH
CARE FIELDS AS WELL. BUT
THANKFULLY, THIS PROGRAM EXISTS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO EXIST TO
HELP US. AND WE PROBABLY OUGHT
TO TAKE A FEW LESSONS FROM
MEXICO. ALL RIGHT. NO OTHER
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES. I
DO BELIEVE YOU HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR ARCHULETA. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? GREAT
QUESTION. I'M SORRY, SENATOR
ROTH MADE THE MOTION. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. GREAT QUESTIONS,
GREAT CONVERSATION. AND I THINK
IT SHEDS LIGHT TO THE MUCH WORK
THAT IS IN FRONT OF US, BUT FOR
NOW, YOU KNOW, THIS BILL IS KIND
OF A SHORT TERM SOLUTION TO A
MAJOR PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE HERE
AS IT RELATES TO ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE, AND WHEN WE HEAR
THAT, YOU KNOW, WHO MEXICO SENDS
TO US, IT'S THEIR BEST. IT'S
THEIR DOCTORS. IT'S YOU KNOW,
THEIR DENTISTS. HOPEFULLY, THAT
WILL BE TAKING CARE OF NOT JUST
PEOPLE WHO SPEAK SPANISH, BUT
ANYONE WHO NEEDS A DOCTOR
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. MOTION FROM SENATOR ROTH.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE
NGUYEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. Ã.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. BECKER
AYE. DODD. DODD. AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO. AYE. NILO.
AYE. ROTH ROTH AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK OKAY. THAT HAS TEN
EYES AND NO NOS. BUT WE WILL
LEAVE IT ON. CALL THANK YOU TO
YOUR WITNESSES. I'M NOT SURE IF
THESE ARE YOUR SAME WITNESSES
FOR THE NEXT ITEM OR NOT, BUT
LET'S GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AB 2864
IS A COMPLEMENTARY BILL. THIS
DEALS JUST WITH THE SIMPLE
PERMITTING AND LICENSING OF
THESE DOCTORS, THE ONE TIME
EXTENSION, SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH THE PROGRAM.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
GREAT COMMENTS. YES. VERY
BRIEFLY, THE PILOT PROGRAM
STARTED IN 2021. THE FIRST TWO
DOCTORS CAME. IT WAS DURING THE
PANDEMIC, THERE WERE A LOT OF,
DIFFICULTIES IN CREDENTIALING
AND A COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS,
NOT WITH MEDI-CAL, BUT IN THE
PRIVATE HEALTH PLANS, THE
DOCTORS REALLY WERE NEVER ABLE
TO BE MAXIMIZED IN TERMS OF
THEIR ACCESS CREATION
CAPABILITIES. WE DO SEE THAT NOW
IN THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF. SO
WE FELT THAT IT WAS A VERY, VERY
FAIR TO EXTEND THESE DOCTORS AN
ADDITIONAL THREE YEARS. BUT
AFTER THESE THREE YEARS, THEY
WILL RETURN. WE DON'T PLAN ON
KEEPING ANYBODY HERE PERMANENTLY
. OKAY. DENNIS ROMERO, WHAT THE
CPC ADVOCATES ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. AND THEN
WE'LL TAKE ME TO TESTIMONY FROM
THE AUDIENCE. HI. GOOD MORNING,
REBECCA ALCANTAR, ON BEHALF OF
ALTAMED, WE'RE ALSO
PARTICIPATING CLINIC IN THE
PROGRAM AND THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
FOR US TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THOSE CRITICAL SERVICES. SO I'M
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE AGAIN.
AARON BOWEN WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED. JUST
WORKING OUT SOME REMAINING
TECHNICAL DETAILS. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM OPPOSED TO THE BILL?
GREAT. THEN WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DICE. ANY COMMENTS HERE,
SENATOR ALVARADO? GIL THANK YOU
AGAIN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA,
ONE THING I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
IN THE DISCUSSION HERE IS THAT
WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
DUAL CITIZENSHIP PROFESSIONALS
THAT BELONG TO BOTH THE US AND
MEXICO AND OTHER CENTRAL
AMERICAN COUNTRIES. AND YOUR
BILL ALLOWS FOR THOSE
PROFESSIONALS TO, TO SERVE IN
THEIR COUNTRIES OF ORIGIN AND
THEIR COUNTRY OF NATIONALITY. SO
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOMETHING THAT
ALREADY EXISTS, AND, YOU KNOW, I
THINK PERSONALLY, I HAVE SEEN
THAT WORK IN VARIOUS PROFESSIONS
, AND, YOU KNOW, TO KEEP OUR,
OUR PROFESSIONAL, WORKFORCE UP
TO DATE. I THINK HAVING THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO STUDY ABROAD,
LIVE ABROAD, AND COME BACK TO
THE US TO PRACTICE IS A
PHENOMENAL OPPORTUNITY. SO THANK
YOU. AND PLEASE, ADD ME AS A
COAUTHOR TO THIS BILL AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SEEING NONE.
IS THAT A MOTION? MOTION.
SENATOR ALVARADO MOVES THE BILL.
YOU HAVE LOTS OF PEOPLE WILLING
TO MOVE YOUR BILL. WE WILL TAKE
THE ROLE. MOTION IS Dð. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASHBY Ã ASHBY I WHEN I WHEN I
ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO. GIL I.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I BECKER.
BECKER I DODD DODD I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GLASER. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I
NILO I NILO I ROTH I ROTH I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. AGAIN.
TEN YESES, NO NOS. BUT WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON. CALL CASE. OTHER
MEMBERS SHOW UP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. GARCIA. WE ARE TAKING
THESE IN FILE ITEM ORDER. SO,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPPIN, YOU ARE
UP NEXT. THANKS FOR HANGING IN
THERE WITH US. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKENNA, WE APPRECIATE YOU. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY,
AB 2037 WILL GIVE COUNTY SEALERS
THE AUTHORITY TO TEST AND VERIFY
MUNICIPALLY OWNED EV CHARGERS.
COUNTY SEALERS ARE TASKED WITH
TESTING AND VERIFYING COMMERCIAL
MEASUREMENT DEVICES SUCH AS
GROCERY SCALES, PUMPS. WHEN YOU
GO TO THE GAS, THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF THAT. THEIR JOB
IS TO MAKE SURE YOU GET WHAT YOU
PAY FOR. VERY SIMPLE CONCEPT.
GENERALLY, THEIR JURISDICTION
COVERS PRIVATELY OWNED EQUIPMENT
AS SUCH, THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
ENTITY IN CHARGE OF PUBLICLY
OWNED EV CHARGERS AND PUBLICLY
OWNED INCLUDES MUNICIPALLY OWNED
ONES. THOSE THAT ARE OWNED BY
CITIES AND COUNTIES, MOSTLY
CITIES, AND THEN ALSO PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES. AS WE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES ON THE LATEST AMENDMENTS,
WHICH REMOVED THE SEALERS
AUTHORITY TO CONDEMN AND SEIZE
INCORRECT CHARGERS, AND SO THEY
HAVE SINCE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION. WE'RE ALSO IN ACTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITY, AND WE ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE LANGUAGE THAT WAS
SENT OVER THIS PAST THURSDAY.
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES REYES,
AND MOVING THEM FORWARD ON THIS
BILL TO ENSURE CONFIDENCE,
IMPARTIALITY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION. IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
COUNTY SEALERS HAVE CLEAR
AUTHORITY TO TEST AND VERIFY
PUBLICLY OWNED EV CHARGERS. YOU
NEED A THIRD PARTY TO DO IT. THE
COST IS ABOUT $26 PER YEAR PER
EV CHARGER. SO WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT HUGE EXPENSES TO DO THIS
WITH INFLATION AND GROWING
INCOME DISPARITY, PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING HARD TIMES WHEN
EVERY DOLLAR COUNTS, IT'S
CRITICAL THAT YOU GET WHAT YOU
PAY FOR. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL ENSURES HERE TO TESTIFY FOR
ME. WITH US TODAY IS MATT
SEIVERLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY SEALERS. GREAT, THANKS.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES, MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS, MATTHEW
SEIBERLING, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION. AGAIN, AB 2037 IS
ALL ABOUT UNIFORMITY, CONSISTENT
èC, FAIRNESS AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION. IF AN ITEM FOR SALE
IS REPRESENTED BY A POUND, A
GALLON OR A METER, THE CONSUMER
MUST BE ABLE TO TRUST THAT THE
DEVICE USED TO ESTABLISH THAT
MEASUREMENT AND THAT PRICE IS
ACCURATE AND TRUSTWORTHY. THIS
CURRENTLY INCLUDES ALL SCALES,
METERS, PUMPS, AND CURRENTLY,
YES, COMMERCIALLY USED EV
CHARGERS THAT ARE OUT IN IN THE
FIELD IN CALIFORNIA. CURRENTLY,
COUNTY SEALERS PROVIDE AN
UNBIASED THIRD PARTY INDEPENDENT
VERIFICATION OF THE ACCURACY OF
COMMERCIAL WEIGHING AND
MEASURING DEVICES. OUR PROGRAM
CONSISTS OF A LOCAL REGISTRATION
OF THE DEVICE PRIOR TO BEING
USED, AND THEN AN ANNUAL
INSPECTION ONCE PER YEAR TO
ENSURE ONGOING ACCURACY. AND
AGAIN, IT'S $26, IN THIS CASE
PER DEVICE PER YEAR. CONSUMER OR
COUNTY SEALERS ALREADY HAVE THE
CURRENT AUTHORITY ENACTED
PROGRAM TO TEST THE ACCURACY OF
METERS ON PRIVATE SECTOR EV
CHARGERS. AS MENTIONED, AND
THESE METERS ARE SUBJECT TO
STRICT STANDARDS AND MUST ADHERE
TO RIGID TOLERANCES IN ORDER TO
BE USED COMMERCIALLY FOR
CONSUMERS, AB 2037 WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL EV CHARGERS AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC WILL MEET THE SAME
ACCURACY STANDARDS AND PROVIDE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
BUSINESSES IN THE INDUSTRY. TO
ENSURE THAT ALL EV CHARGERS
USERS WILL BENEFIT FROM THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION PROVIDED BY
OUR PROGRAM AND TO ENSURE
UNIFORMITY IN THE EV
MARKETPLACE, WE URGE SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE THERE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM?
ME TWO TESTIMONY. YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION POSITION ON THE
BILL. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR AND THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
DILLON ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF
BEHALF OF PLACER COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
BEING HERE. OKAY. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL TO AB 2037? ARE YOU
A LEAD WITNESS? COME ON.
FORWARD. YOU CAN COME UP TO THE
TABLE. THERE ARE TWO OF YOU. YOU
CAN EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
SPEAK. YOU CAN STAY AT THE TABLE
IN CASE FOLKS HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
YOU. GO AHEAD AND HAVE A SEAT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, GREG
COOK, REPRESENTING THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY, A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY CONSISTING OF
16 PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES. THE STATE
CONSTITUTION GIVES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PROVISION OF ELECTRICITY TO
THEIR CONSUMERS. AND 16 OF OUR
ALL OF OUR 16 MEMBERS AND 40
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCEPTED THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. AND THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SAFE,
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE
ELECTRICITY SERVICE WE ARE FULLY
INTEGRATED. WE PROVIDE THE
ELECTRICITY THROUGH OUR OWN
GENERATION OR THROUGH
CONTRACTUAL BASIS. WE DISTRIBUTE
THAT ELECTRICITY THROUGH OUR OWN
LOCAL, LOCALLY OWNED UTILITY
LINES. WE PROVIDE THAT TO OUR
CUSTOMERS ON A 24 HOUR A DAY
BASIS FOR SAFE SERVICE. AND WE
PROVIDE THE MOST AFFORDABLE
RATES. THIS BILL, WE BELIEVE, IS
UNNECESSARY AS IT RELATES TO
PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES. WE TAKE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY VERY SERIOUSLY.
OUR CITY COUNCILS AND GOVERNING
BOARDS TAKE IT EQUALLY
RESPONSIBLE, EQUALLY SERIOUSLY.
AS A RESULT, UNFORTUNATELY, WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN
ITS PRESENT FORM. WE HAVE
SUGGESTED TO THE AUTHOR AN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD, I BELIEVE,
ENHANCE CONSUMER PROTECTION
BECAUSE IT WOULD PROVIDE THAT
EACH OF THE PUBLIC ELECTRIC
UTILITIES WOULD PROVIDE IN A
CONSPICUOUS AND A CONSPICUOUS
BASIS ON THE ELECTRIC CHARGER
ITSELF. IF THE NAME OF THE
COMMUNITY WHICH IS PROVIDING THE
SERVICE AND CONSUMER
INFORMATION, HOW YOU CAN CONTACT
THAT UTILITY IF YOU HAVE A
CONCERN. BUT OUR UTILITIES ARE
MONITORING EVERY SERVICE THEY
PROVIDE, WHETHER IT'S TO YOUR
HOME, YOUR BUSINESS OR IN
TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT TO YOUR
VEHICLE. IF WE OFFER YOU THAT
SERVICE, WE GUARANTEE RELIABLE,
SAFE AND COST EFFECTIVE
ELECTRICITY. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY. NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. I'M DOCTOR NATALIE
SEITZMAN WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY. PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY. I'M GOING TO USE ONE
OF OUR 12 PLU MEMBERS, BURBANK
WATER AND POWER, AS AN EXAMPLE
OF THE BREADTH AND EXPANSIVENESS
AND EFFICACY OF IN-HOUSE
INSPECTIONS PERFORMED BY POWER'S
, WHO OWN OR OPERATE EV
CHARGERS. BURBANK OPERATES 55
PUBLIC CHARGERS AND HAS BEEN
RUNNING A ROBUST INSPECTION
PROGRAM FOR THEM SINCE 2016.
THEY SEND OUT TRAINED
ELECTRICIANS TO INSPECT THEM ON
A MONTHLY BASIS. THIS MONTHLY
INSPECTION IS EXTENSIVE AND IS
INCLUSIVE OF THE SINGLE TEST
THAT AB 2037 PROPOSES SHOULD BE
PERFORMED BY COUNTY SEALERS WHO
HAVE NO SPECIAL EXPERTISE IN THE
OPERATION OR REPAIR OF EV
CHARGERS. IN ADDITION TO MONTHLY
INSPECTIONS, THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PATHWAYS FOR CUSTOMERS TO REPORT
ISSUES WITH CHARGERS, WHICH WILL
NOTIFY THE ELECTRICAL SUPERVISOR
TO DISPATCH ELECTRICIANS AS
NEEDED. WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND
ENSURING THAT EV CHARGERS ARE IN
GOOD CONDITION, AS WELL AS
TURNAROUND REPAIRS QUICKLY TO
BRING CHARGERS BACK ONLINE, AS
EVIDENCED BY BURBANK WATER AND
POWER'S CHARGERS, WHICH ENJOY A
99.01% UPTIME, WE BELIEVE THAT
THE PLU IS BETTER POSITIONED TO
INSPECT MORE FREQUENTLY AND MORE
EXTENSIVELY, WE THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR COMMITTING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS, BUT REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED AT THIS TIME.
GREAT. ARE THERE PEOPLE HERE IN
THE ROOM WHO ARE ME TO
OPPOSITION AS WELL? GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING. KIARA ROSS, ON
BEHALF OF BURBANK WATER AND
POWER, WE REMAIN IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL, BUT ARE THANKFUL TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSING THE BILL IN
THE ROOM TODAY? OKAY, BEFORE I
GIVE IT TO MY COLLEAGUES, I JUST
WANT TO SAY I DID NOT ISSUE A
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS BILL,
WHICH MEANS I DIDN'T TRY TO
INFLUENCE MY COLLEAGUES. THEY
ARE FREE TO VOTE HOWEVER THEY
WOULD LIKE. HOWEVER, I THE
REASON I DID NOT IS BECAUSE
SMUD, WHILE THEY HAVE NOT TAKEN
A POSITION ON THIS BILL, THEY
ARE A PART OF THE ORGANIZATION
THAT HAS CONCERNS. I INTEND TO
VOTE YES TODAY IN ORDER TO GIVE
THE AUTHOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES,
PARTICULARLY SMUD, AND I'LL BE
WAITING TO HEAR THAT FEEDBACK
WHEN AND IF THIS ITEM COMES TO
THE FLOOR. SO COLLEAGUES. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR ROTH AND THEN
SENATOR MENGIBAR, I'M JUST
CURIOUS, WHAT'S THE ARE THERE
ANY STATISTICS, TO NOTE THE
ACCURACY OR OUT OF SERVICE RATE
FOR EV CHARGERS AND MUNICIPAL
CITIES WITH PUBLIC POWER
AGENCIES? THE ACCURACY OF THE,
WELL, I'M TRYING TO ARE THERE
ARE THERE SOME STATISTICS TO
SHOW THE OUT OF SERVICE RATE OR
ACCURACY, WHICH IS WHAT THE
SEALERS ARE TALKING ABOUT WITH
RESPECT TO EV CHARGERS OWNED BY
MUNICIPALITIES WITH PUBLIC POWER
AGENCIES? I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY WITNESS, IF THAT'S OKAY.
SENATOR ROTH, SIR. SO THE ENTIRE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL, JUST ON, ON
ITS MOST BASE LEVEL, IS TO
PROVIDE THE SEALERS AUTHORITY TO
ACTUALLY GO IN AND BEGIN TESTING
. I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY. WHY THE BILL? I UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU WANT TO DO IT RIGHT. I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIND OUT THE WHY
HERE. ALL RIGHT, I'LL ANSWER
THAT PART. WELL, CURRENTLY,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE ANY DATA
BECAUSE THERE IS NO CURRENT
TESTING. SO THAT KIND OF LEAVES
US AT A BIT OF A DISADVANTAGE.
BUT REALLY THE BILL IS ABOUT
GETTING AN INDEPENDENT THIRD
PARTY OUT THERE, NOT HAVING THE
FOX WITH THE CHICKENS, IF YOU
WILL, LIKE WE DO FOR EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT IS MEASURED, WHETHER
IT'S BUYING FRUIT AT THE STORE
OR BUYING GASOLINE, SO THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS, A BELIEF THAT WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING AND THEY'RE
GETTING WHAT THEY PAY FOR, AN
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY WILL
ALLOW THAT. PEACE OF MIND, IF
YOU WILL. AND I DON'T WANT TO
CONFUSE AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS THAT THE
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES DO WITH
RESPECT TO THEIR OWN CHARGERS
AND HAVING PEOPLE GO OUT TO
MAINTAIN EV CHARGERS IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT. BUT THIS
IS ABOUT THE ACCURACY OF IT. YOU
KNOW, WE COULD GO AND PUMP GAS
ANY DAY OF THE WEEK. WE DON'T
KNOW WHETHER IT'S ACCURATE OR
NOT ACCURATE WHEN WE'RE PUMPING
THE GAS. BUT WE DO NOW BECAUSE
WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE WHERE
THOSE PUMPS ARE TESTED
PERIODICALLY SO THAT THEY KNOW
THAT THE PUBLIC IS GETTING WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU SPEND NOW $5 A
GALLON OR WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE,
YOU'RE ACTUALLY GETTING THAT
GALLON. SO THERE'S WE DON'T WANT
TO CONFLATE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MAINTAINING AND ACCURACY
TO THE PUBLIC. SO THIS BILL, YOU
ASK, WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS THE GOOD FAITH THAT
THEY'RE GETTING WHAT THEY PAY
FOR, AND THERE IS ACCURACY TO
WHAT THEY'RE PAYING FOR. SO DO
DO THE SEALERS TEST. THE COUNTY
OWNED EV CHARGERS TODAY? NO,
SIR. NO, WE ONLY TEST THE
PRIVATELY OWNED PRIVATE SECTOR
EV CHARGERS. SO IT'S THE
CHARGEPOINT, THE TESLA, CHARGERS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO ANYBODY
THAT'S DRIVING AROUND BASICALLY,
IF AGAIN, PURPOSE OF THE BILL,
IF YOU'RE DRIVING DOWN THE
STREET AND THERE'S PUBLICLY
OWNED CITY OPERATED CHARGERS ON
THE LEFT, PRIVATELY OWNED
CHARGERS ON THE RIGHT, THESE ARE
BEING INSPECTED BY COUNTY
SEALERS. THESE ARE NOT AND THE
BILL IS BASICALLY TO PERFORM,
UNIFORM INSPECTIONS. OVERALL TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY THAT
USES ANY DEVICE THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO THEM CAN BE ASSURED THAT IT
ACTUALLY WORKS. CITIES AND
COUNTIES, CORRECT. CITIES,
COUNTIES AND STATES. AND MY
OTHER QUESTION IS WHY? IF
ACCURACY IS AN ISSUE, WHY DO IT
THIS WAY? WHY NOT MANDATE? FOR
PUBLICLY OWNED POWER AGENCIES
THAT OWN AND OPERATE EV
CHARGERS? WHY NOT MANDATE AN
INSPECTION SCHEDULE OR ACCURACY
TESTING SCHEDULE, THE VARIOUS
THINGS THAT THE COUNTY SEALERS
ARE PROPOSING TO DO HERE INSTEAD
OF CHARGING THE MUNICIPALITY AND
THE MUNICIPALLY OWNED POWER
AGENCY TO DO THE WORK. IS THAT A
FAIR QUESTION? FRANKLY, WE JUST
DON'T ALLOW FOR ANY
SELF-ATTESTATION IN ANY OTHER
PART OF THE MARKETPLACE.
BASICALLY, WE DON'T ALLOW PEOPLE
TO TEST THEIR OWN DEVICES AND
THEN LET US KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE ACCURATE. IT'S A THIRD
PARTY INDEPENDENT TEST PROVIDED
BY THE SEALER, AGAIN, IN ANY ANY
IMAGINABLE AREA OF THE
MARKETPLACE. WELL, IT'S NOT
THIRD PARTY IF YOU'RE INSPECTING
YOUR OWN COUNTY. CORRECT. RIGHT,
RIGHT. SO WHAT WOULD STOP THE
CITY AND THE MUNICIPAL MUNICIPAL
OWNED POWER AGENCY FROM HIRING A
SERIES OF SEALERS TO INSPECT
THEIR OWN EV CHARGERS? WELL,
BECAUSE COUNTY SEALERS ARE
LICENSED AND TRAINED AND MANAGED
BY THE DIVISION OF MEASUREMENT
STANDARDS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. AND THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY THEIR ROLE AND THEIR
SOLE PURPOSE WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS TO PROVIDE WEIGHTS
AND MEASURES, TESTING. WELL,
I'LL, PROBABLY LAY OFF THE
MEASURE TODAY, MA'AM. I KNOW I
YOU'RE AN EXCEPTIONAL AUTHOR,
AND I RESPECT YOUR WORK, AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT YOU WILL WORK
THROUGH THIS. SO THAT THE NEXT
TIME I HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE ON IT, I'LL BE SUPPORTIVE
OF IT. THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
OKAY, SENATOR MENGIBAR AND THEN
ALVARADO AND THEN NILO. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WE BRIEFLY TALKED ABOUT
THIS, ONE OF THE OPPOSITIONS IS
THE, YOU KNOW, THE POO IN MY
VERY DISTRICT. AND YOU HEARD
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT IT WAS
CHOSEN AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
SUCCESS RATES AND HOW WELL THEY
MAINTAIN. BUT I KNOW YOU'VE MADE
A POINT THAT THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT MAINTAINING, IT'S ABOUT
ACCURACY. SO TO THAT, I'D LIKE
TO ASK THE QUESTION TO THE
OPPOSITION, THE WORK THAT, THAT
IS BEING DONE ON THE ACCURACY OF
THE EV CHARGERS AS WELL, THANK
YOU, SENATOR, A TESTING KIT TO
MEASURE THE ACCURACY TO TEST
THAT THE AMOUNT OF ELECTRICITY
BEING DISCHARGED IS AS EXPECTED,
IS INCLUDED IN THOSE MONTHLY
INSPECTIONS. SO WE DO A BROAD
LEVEL OF INSPECTION FOR ALL OF
THE ASPECTS OF THE CHARGER,
INCLUDING THE ACCURACY. OKAY SO
IS IT IS IT YOUR ASSUMPTION
RIGHT NOW THAT THE CONSUMER IS
GETTING THE ELECTRICITY CHARGE
FOR WHAT THEY'RE PAYING FOR?
THAT WOULD BE PART OF THE TEST?
YES. AND IF THIS WENT THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATION WENT THROUGH,
WOULD YOU CEASE ALL THAT KIND OF
MAINTENANCE AND INSPECTION AND
WOULD HAVE TO USE THE COUNTY
SEALERS TO DO THE WORK THEN, I
CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF EACH
INDIVIDUAL PO AS TO WHAT THEIR
OPERATIONS DECISIONS MIGHT BE,
BUT THE COUNTY SEALERS ANNUAL
INSPECTION WOULD NOT REPLACE
THE, LEVEL OF CUSTOMER
PROTECTION THAT A MONTHLY
INSPECTION WOULD PROVIDE. SO IT
WOULD BE ON TOP. AND THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
APPROXIMATELY $26 A YEAR. WHERE
WOULD WE SEE THAT BE REFLECTED?
WOULD THAT GO DOWN TO CONSUMERS,
AS A PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY IS
NOT NONPROFIT, SO THERE WOULD BE
NOWHERE ELSE FOR THOSE CHARGES
TO COME FROM. THEN THE CONSUMERS
IN SOME WAY. OKAY. THANK YOU
SIR, I APOLOGIZE. I DIDN'T GET
YOUR NAME THERE. MADAM CHAIR.
CAN I ASK ANOTHER QUESTION? SURE
I HAD VERY SIMILAR QUESTIONS TO
SENATOR ROTH REGARDING. AND I
BELIEVE THIS IS ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS IS ASKING. AND SO
MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER THIS AS
WELL. ASKING THE POWER'S TO DO
AT THAT SAME LEVEL, OF ACCURACY,
IF YOURS IS ONLY ONCE A YEAR AND
SOME PEOPLE ARE DOING ONCE A
MONTH FOR ME, THE MATH SEEMS
LIKE THIS IS A BETTER APPROACH
THAN ANNUALLY. SO WHAT? WHAT,
WHAT'S THE WORD I'M LOOKING FOR?
WHAT ADDED VALUE IS THE ONCE
ANNUALLY VERSUS MONTHLY BRING.
YEAH, I JUST MADAM CHAIR. YES
THANK YOU, SO I THINK THE BEST
WAY TO EXPLAIN THIS IS, IS TO
JUST APPLY THE METHODOLOGY THAT
WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO APPLY TO
THIS INDUSTRY, AND LOOK AT
VIRTUALLY ANY OTHER SITUATION
YOU'D BE MUCH MORE FAMILIAR
WITH, LIKE GAS STATIONS, FOR
EXAMPLE, WE WOULD ENCOURAGE AND
MOST GAS STATIONS DO, PROBABLY
LIKELY MONTHLY TESTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR GAS PUMPS ARE
ACTUALLY PUMPING OUT THE AMOUNT
THAT THEIR METER IS CLAIMING
THAT IT'S PUMPING OUT, AND
ESSENTIALLY, FOR THEIR CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND FOR THE LOGO THAT
THEY HAVE FORWARD FACING TO THE
PUBLIC TO BE TRUSTWORTHY, WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THEY DO THAT. WE
ENCOURAGE THEM TO CONTINUE DOING
THAT, ESSENTIALLY, OUR PROGRAM
IS LOOKED AT AS A VERIFICATION
THAT, YOU KNOW, WHEN WE SHOW UP
UNANNOUNCED AND WE TEST THAT
DEVICE, WHETHER IT BE A JEWELRY
SCALE OR A SCALE AT THE GROCERY
STORE OR A GAS PUMP OR AN EV
CHARGER, OUR INSPECTOR CAN LOOK
AT THAT METER, BE CHARGED AN
AMOUNT THAT REFLECTS WHAT THAT
METER SAYS THE PRICE SHOULD BE,
AND WE'RE ON OUR WAY. SO IT'S
MORE OR LESS A SPOT CHECK
VERIFICATION. WE THEN WE AFFIX
LITERALLY A SEAL ONTO THE DEVICE
THAT SAYS, WE WERE HERE ON THIS
DATE IN THIS COUNTY, AND WE MOVE
ON AND, BASICALLY OUR RESPONSE
FROM THAT POINT ON TO COMPLAINTS
OR TO REQUESTS FROM THE DEVICE
OPERATOR TO COME BACK AND RETEST
IF THEY'D LIKE. BUT OTHERWISE
IT'S A GOOD SEAL, GOOD
HOUSEKEEPING SEAL, ESSENTIALLY.
YEAH, EXACTLY. IT IS THE
INDEPENDENT PARTY, IF YOU WILL.
I USE THE ANALOGY OF THE FOX
WITH THE CHICKENS, AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE OPERATORS CAN
NEVER, GIVE YOU. I IT IS
ADMIRABLE WORK AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THEY'RE DOING IT ON THEIR
OWN. I WILL SAY A LOT OF GAS
STATIONS TEST ON THEIR OWN ALSO
FOR THEIR OWN BENEFIT, BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE SELLING
MORE OR GIVING AWAY IF YOU WILL,
MORE GASOLINE THAN THAN WHAT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY PAYING FOR. SO
IT CAN WORK BOTH WAYS. BUT IT IS
THE INDEPENDENCE THAT THE
SEALERS WILL PROVIDE. MY LAST
COMMENT ON THIS WOULD BE, AND I
THINK SENATOR RON ROTH POINTED
TO THE FACT THAT AS A COUNTY
SEALER, YOU'RE STILL DOING YOUR
OWN, EV CHARGERS. SO THEY'RE
KIND OF LIKE NEGATES THE
INDEPENDENCY OF IT. OR THE THIRD
PARTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER I SHARED
THAT I WILL GO UP ON THIS BILL.
I'M NOT GOING TO CHANGE MY WORD.
I DO ASK THAT. AND YOU WILL. YOU
COMMITTED TO ME THAT YOU WILL BE
WORKING, TO FIND SOME COMPROMISE
WITH THE POE USE. THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ME, AND I AM
RESERVING MY RIGHT TO CHANGE MY
VOTE ON THE SENATE FLOOR. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ALVARADO. GILL ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR POPPEN, I'M IN A
QUANDARY HERE THAT OFTEN THE
TAHOE BASIN IS ALIGNED ON, ON
BILLS THAT COME TO US AND ON
YOUR BILL. THEY'RE NOT, SO I
HAVE, THE, THE TRUCKEE DONNER
AREA, AS WELL AS THE KINGS BEACH
TAHOE CITY AREA IN CONFLICT ON
THIS BILL. SO I'M GOING TO LAY
OFF TODAY UNTIL I CAN DIVE A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER INTO THAT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I REALLY DO LOOK
TO THE TAHOE BASIN, THE MONO
BASIN TO BE ABLE TO LEAD ON SOME
OF OUR ENERGY DECISIONS AND SOME
OF OUR, EV POLICY. SO, I'M GOING
TO HOLD BACK, BUT WE'LL COME
BACK WITH SOME MORE, MORE DATA
FOR YOU. THANK YOU. GREAT.
SENATOR NIELLO, I WANT HER
DISTRICT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND I PROMISE THIS IS
GOING TO BE A QUICK QUESTION,
OKAY? WHETHER IT'S A QUICK
ANSWER OR NOT, I CAN'T REST,
THIS AUTHORIZES AND DOESN'T
MANDATE, BUT NONETHELESS, DO
COUNTIES HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
TAKE ON THIS ADDITIONAL WORK,
WHICH FOR SOME COUNTIES MIGHT BE
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT THEY DO OTHERWISE? DO THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES CURRENTLY, IT
VARIES. I KNOW IT'S NOT A GREAT
ANSWER, WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN IN OUR POWER TO GET UP TO
SPEED ON THIS RAPIDLY EVOLVING
AND EXPLODING TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
OUT IN THE FIELD, BUT I THINK
FIRST AND FOREMOST, WHICH IS THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL, WE NEEDED
TO SECURE THAT AUTHORITY IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TESTING IS UNIFORM AND WE'RE NOT
PICKING AND CHOOSING BETWEEN
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SECTOR TO
ACTUALLY ADMINISTER OUR PROGRAM.
BUT OVER TIME, WE WOULD HOPE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE COUNTIES AND
THE STATE WOULD INVEST IN THE
PROGRAM TO THE LEVEL APPROPRIATE
TO ALLOW FOR THAT TESTING TO
TAKE PLACE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
YOU SAY THE COUNTY AND THE
STATE, IF A COUNTY AGREED, WANTS
TO DO THIS. IT'S GOING TO COME
OUT OF COUNTY RESOURCES
CURRENTLY. YES. YEAH YEAH, THAT
WAS WISHFUL THINKING. ALTHOUGH I
WILL SAY THAT SOME OF THE FEES
DO DO GO TOWARDS PROVIDING THE
SERVICE OF TESTING THE
EQUIPMENT. SO AND WE, I ACTUALLY
CARRIED A BILL LAST YEAR THAT
THAT DID INCREASE SOME OF THE
FEES SO THAT THEY HADN'T BEEN
INCREASED SINCE. WAS IT. YEAH.
ABOUT 2008. SO WE'RE HOPING THAT
IT IS MORE SELF-SUFFICIENT AS
WELL. THERE IS A MECHANISM
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE DAIS, WOULD YOU LIKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE? I WOULD
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR,
AND I APPRECIATE THE DISCOURSE
HERE, AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION. YOU
HAVE MY REPRESENTATION AS SUCH.
WE'RE REALLY JUST TRYING TO
BALANCE PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
WITH WITHOUT BEING OVERLY
BURDENSOME. AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THE
BILL TODAY AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. NEED A
MOTION MOVED BY SENATOR EGGMAN?
WE WILL TAKE THE ROLL. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. ASHBY AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. WHEN? WHEN I. ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA. Ã. ARCHULETA
AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD
AYE. DODD. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
AYE. NILO NILO. AYE. ROTH
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WELK EIGHT
YESES, NO. NOS. WE'LL LEAVE THE
ITEM ON CALL. AND FOR OTHER
MEMBERS WHEN THEY GET HERE.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING.
APPRECIATE YOU. MEMBER. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MCKENNA
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. FROM THIS POINT ON,
I'M GOING TO CHANGE MY OWN RULE.
WE'RE NO LONGER GOING TO TAKE
THINGS IN FILE ORDER. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE IT BASED ON THE
MEMBER WHO'S HERE. BECAUSE YOU
WAITED ENTIRELY TOO LONG TO BE
HEARD. SO I APPRECIATE YOU AND
JUST KNOW YOU'RE THE REASON FOR
ME CHANGING THAT RULE NOW FOR
BNP. OKAY. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD AND TAKE US FORWARD. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 3063, WHICH WOULD
CLARIFY THE ADDITION OF
FLAVORING AGENT TO ENHANCE THE
TASTE OF A PRESCRIPTION DOES NOT
CONSTITUTE COMPOUNDING. THIS
BILL WAS UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED
LAST YEAR IN THIS COMMITTEE, BUT
WAS UNFORTUNATELY VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR. AS A RESULT, ON
NOVEMBER 1ST, 2023, THE NUMBER
OF PHARMACIES PROVIDING
FLAVORING DROPPED FROM 3100 TO
ROUGHLY 30 TOTAL, A WHOPPING
99.5% REDUCTION IN ACCESS TO
SERVICE LITERALLY OVERNIGHT. WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN DISCUSSION WITH
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY ON
AMENDMENTS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY RESOLVE THE CONCERN
OF BOTH THE BOARD AND THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE. WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL REACH A
COMPROMISE AS SOON AS WE CAN
BRING THE PRACTICE OF FLAVORING
BACK TO THE INDEPENDENT AND
RETAIL PHARMACIES, THEREBY
MAKING IT EASIER FOR PARENTS,
CHILDREN AND THOSE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICINE THAT
WILL ACTUALLY TASTE GOOD IN THE
MEANTIME, DUE TO THE URGENCY OF
THIS ISSUE, THE BILL IS IN THE
FORM YOU WILL ALL APPROVE.
TODAY. I'M LAST YEAR. I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL APPROVE THIS
MEASURE AS IS TO MOVE IT ALONG
AS WE WORK OUT A SOLUTION.
JOINING ME TODAY IS LINDSAY
GULLAHORN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY PHARMACY
COALITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. LINDSAY GULLAHORN
WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION COMMUNITY
PHARMACY COALITION, PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB 3063, WHICH, AS YOU
HEARD, WILL CLARIFY THAT ADDING
FLAVORING AGENTS TO MEDICATIONS
AND PHARMACIES IS NOT CONSIDERED
COMPOUNDING, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR PHARMACISTS TO BE ABLE TO
ADD FLAVORING TO CHILDREN'S
MEDICATIONS WHEN PRESCRIBING,
BECAUSE WHEN PRESCRIBING MANY
COMMON LIQUID MEDICATIONS TO
CHILDREN, PRESCRIBERS OFTEN
DON'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT INTO
ACCOUNT THE FLAVOR OF THE
MEDICINE. THIS IS WHERE
PHARMACIES COME INTO PLAY. THEY
ARE ABLE TO ADD FLAVORING TO
LIQUIDS AND SUSPENSIONS, WHICH
IMPROVES TASTE AND INCREASES
MEDICATION ADHERENCE. OVER THE
PAST DECADE, MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN'S MEDICATIONS HAVE BEEN
FLAVORED IN CALIFORNIA
PHARMACIES WITH NO NEGATIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES, DUE TO RECENT
REGULATORY ACTION BY THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY. MOST PHARMACIES, AS
YOU'VE HEARD IN CALIFORNIA, HAVE
STOPPED OFFERING FLAVORING,
WHICH IS PUTTING CHILDREN AT
RISK WHO MAY REFUSE TO TAKE
THEIR MEDICATIONS, OR FORCING
PARENTS TO INVENT THEIR OWN
POSSIBLY DANGEROUS APPROACHES TO
PERSUADE THEIR CHILDREN TO TAKE
THEIR MEDICATION. SO WITHOUT
THIS BILL, MOST PHARMACIES WILL
CONTINUE TO NOT BE ABLE TO ADD
FLAVORING TO MEDICATIONS BECAUSE
OF THE NEW REQUIREMENTS THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE TO ADHERE TO DO
SO, UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL BY THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY. THERE WAS A
VETO, LAST YEAR. HOWEVER, WE ARE
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR THAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE BOARD ARE
ONGOING AND THAT THE BOARD IS
WILLING TO CONSIDER AMENDMENTS
THAT MAY ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
SO WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUE AND THAT PHARMACIES CAN
RESUME OFFERING FLAVORING, WHICH
WILL AGAIN INCREASE MEDICATION
ADHERENCE, ESPECIALLY AMONG
CHILDREN. THANKS. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I SEE SOME
ME TWO TESTIMONY LINED UP. COME
ON. FORWARD GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. AARON
NORWOOD REPRESENTING FLAVOR. WE
PARTNER WITH THE RETAIL
PHARMACIES TO OFFER FLAVORING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANKS
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, KELLY
MACMILLAN WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB 3063
SEEING NO ONE? WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DÍAS COLLEAGUES. ANY
COMMENT? ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE A
MOTION. WELL, NOW, WAIT A MINUTE
. SENATOR EGGMAN HAS TO SING HER
RENDITION OF THAT MARY POPPINS
SONG, THANK YOU, SIR, BUT I DID
POINT OUT I SANG TWICE LAST YEAR
AND IT WAS VETOED, SO I THINK
I'M GOING TO ABSTAIN. THAT IS
HER CONTRIBUTION TO HELPING YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KENNER, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE OR WOULD YOU
RATHER SENATOR EGGMAN SANG
SPOONFUL OF SUGAR UP TO YOU.
JUST A SPOON FULL OF SUGAR HELPS
THE MEDICINE GO DOWN THE
MEDICINE, GO DOWN THE MEDICINE.
GO DOWN. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE IN THE MOST
DELIGHTFUL WAY. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH, WE HAVE. WE HAD A
MOTION. YES, WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR ROTH. WE WILL TAKE
THE ROLL. WE WILL SEE IF WE CAN
GET A DIFFERENT ANSWER FROM OUR
GOVERNOR. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ASHBY AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. WHEN I WHEN I. ALVARADO.
GIL. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD DODD.
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO.
AYE NILA. AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
SMALL WITH CUEVAS. WILK. AYE.
WILK. AYE. VIÆT LEVIN. YESES.
NO. NOS. SEE WHAT WE CAN DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WITH US
COLLEAGUES. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR, FILE ITEM NUMBER
3AB2269 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FLORA HAS BEEN PULLED FROM OUR
AGENDA TODAY, SO THAT MAKES UP
OUR FULL AGENDA. IF YOU'VE BEEN
HERE THE WHOLE TIME MEANS YOU
HAVE ALREADY VOTED ON
EVERYTHING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR DOING SO. WE ARE GOING TO
RUN THROUGH THE ORDER AGAIN
HERE. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WEREN'T HERE, LET'S START WITH
FILE ITEM ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY 1775 CANNABIS BILL. IT HAS
TWO NOES AND FIVE AYES. ASHBY OR
EXCUSE ME, CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. ALVARADO EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GLASER. MENGIBAR.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK I WILK I
THAT'S 7 TO 2. WE WILL LEAVE IT
ON. CALL NEXT ITEM FILE ITEM
TWO. THIS IS POPPINS WEIGHTS AND
MEASURES. BILL AB2037. IT HAS
EIGHT EYES AND NO NOS. PLEASE
CALL THE FULL ROLL EVERY MEMBER.
YEAH. MOTION HAS TO DO. PASS THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE VOTES
8 TO 0. CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ALVARADO GIL.
GLASER. ROTH SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. Ã. WILK. AYE. NINE OKAY.
NINE TO NOTHING THAT WE WILL
LEAVE ON CALL AS WELL. NEXT
ITEM. WE PULLED ITEM THREE. SO
WE'RE TAKING FILE ITEM FOUR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON'S AB
2471. THIS IS HIS PUBLIC NURSE,
BILL. HE SITS AT NINE EYES. NO
NOSE. MOTION IS DUE. PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. GLASER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE ALL
RIGHT. THAT ITEM GETS OUT 12 TO
NOTHING. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FIVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA,
THIS IS THE LICENSED PHYSICIANS
AND DENTISTS FROM MEXICO
PROGRAM. HE CURRENTLY SITS AT
TEN EYES, NO NOSE MOTION IS DO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK. WILK. AYE. ALL RIGHT. 12
TO NOTHING. THAT ONE GETS OUT AS
WELL. THE NEXT GARCIA BILL. FILE
ITEM SIX AB 2864. ALSO ABOUT THE
LICENSED PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS. THIS ONE'S AN
EXTENSION OF THE LICENSES.
SITTING AT TEN EYES, NO NOSE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
GLASER GLASER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. AGAIN, 12 EYES, NO NO'S.
THAT ITEM MOVES ON. LAST FILE,
ITEM SEVEN, THIS IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCKINNEY AB 3063. HER
COMPOUNDING PHARMACIES BILL. IT
CURRENTLY SITS WITH 11 EYES AND
NO NO'S. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
ALL RIGHT. THAT'S 12 EYES. NO
NO'S THAT ITEM ALSO GETS OUT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO ITEM
ONE MORE TIME HERE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY 1775. HIS CANNABIS
RETAIL PREPARATION AND FOOD
CONSUMPTION BILL. IT SITS WITH
TWO NO'S AND SEVEN EYES. CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
ALVARADO. GIL. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE GLASER. BLAZER AYE.
MENGIBAR. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S NINE EYES AND TWO
NOS. THAT BILL ALSO GETS OUT.
FILE ITEM TWO, THIS IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPPIN 2037. HER WEIGHTS
AND MEASURES ON ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGES. SHE CURRENTLY SITS AT
NINE EYES AND NO. NOS CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. ALVARADO
GIL GLASER. ALL RIGHT, HOLD ON.
ROTH SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. NINE EYES. NO. NOS
THAT ITEM GETS OUT. THAT IS THE
END OF OUR AGENDA TODAY BECAUSE
WE PULLED ITEM THREE. THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUES AND TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR PRESENTING
THEIR BILLS TODAY. THAT'S IT FOR
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.